father said look ma
what do you reject Nations John Humphrey
here coming at your life and direct
Allah there's a new Punisher trailer
let's get into this right now the past
more than race oh it's the devil you
sold your soul to
[Music]
he's physically
[Music]
that really cool whoo I just watch that
again just for me there's not time to
dive into with this you know it is just
a teaser trailer but right off the bat
the images are all really cool the mood
is definitely dark and foreboding and
you know it has a violent feel to it you
know you're watching ostensibly Frank
Castle pound with a mallet his signature
you know motif his skull logo into the
cement I guess the thing that this
teaser makes me wonder the most is where
the timeline is going to go I'm curious
as to what we're going to see from the
path to so much of this teaser he's
talking about the past and the Punishers
past is a huge part of his character so
I got to imagine while the story
progresses in the present because you
know Deborah Ann Woll is credited Karen
page as a part of this like I got
imagine most of the main action will
take place in the present or at least on
the present timeline of daredevil and
the defenders and stuff but I have to
assume that in this show with more
breathing room probably going to go back
and see more of his past some of the
images in this trailer suggest that to
me at least his military past we've seen
the Punishers origin on screen before
but none to place where he is the focus
of an entire TV series so I have to
imagine that we're going to go back and
we're going to see the you know cost of
Central Park Massacre we're probably
going to see some of his military
background has come up there is a marine
captain getting as a Navy SEAL status
maybe even some of his time starting to
become a priest just because you know
daredevil has that running Church motif
because this is a spinoff
right out of that universe at least in
terms of the TV series you know the
Punisher originally spun off from
spider-man I wouldn't be surprised if
that debate came in there too because
it's a part of Frank's past as part of
his history friends this got Stigliano
just in my own personal opinion I think
Jon Bernthal is a terrific actor as one
of those guys I'm always excited when I
hear he's in something or when he pops
up in something I really like his
portrayal of the Punisher in daredevil
season 2 and I've got a quote from him
here it says for me it's not a question
of what they want to do with the
character it's more how are they going
to do it and who's going to be the ones
to do it this character is in my bones
now he's in my blood if they want to go
forward in any way for me it's really
just going to be about making sure we do
it in a way that's raw and in 10
I want to push the envelope I want to
alienate more of the audience and try to
bring them back and I don't know how old
a quote is to be honest with you but I
do think that that is an interesting way
to take this and I hope that that comes
through here because you know this is a
gritty looking trailer it's an imposing
trailer you're watching I pound concrete
feels violent and the Punisher is a
violent character that's that part of
the point and I think you could have a
very fascinating antihero story even
further down the rabbit hole because
there if I mean like there's a lot of
deconstructing that goes on in these
Marvel TV shows especially daredevil
especially Jessica Jones I feel like the
Punisher has potential to do that in an
even darker even more challenging way
and the idea like he says of pushing the
envelope of alienating even more of the
audience pushing their limits and then
bringing them back I think can make this
a really exciting season of TV if they
nail it it seems like it got all the
right things in place to do that the
showrunner for this is Steve Lightfoot
who is one of the executive producers
and Hannibal was just a show I still
have to see [ __ ] because I don't get to
watch much TV for fun - everything I've
heard about that show it's been terrific
and I know that that is an anti-hero
show you know and it's a dark show that
pedigree alone coming over here I know
he wasn't the showrunner over there but
coming over here The Punisher you
definitely see the potential I can see
why they chose this guy so I'm really
excited to see this moving forward as
far as Marvel properties go this is one
of the things I'm looking forward to the
most right now this is close to the top
of my comic book list whatever that
might be a little bummed to hear that a
Claire temple is not going to show up in
this I really love when she shows up in
the Marvel shows but you know I'm
excited that we're going to see more
campaign and I'm just excited to see Jon
Bernthal do he's being you know a
hundred percent you know to focus in on
that so uh yeah I'm really excited about
this I think it's just a badass teaser
so that's me
what are you going to think I mean as
Punisher fans are you guys excited about
what you're seeing here I know it's not
a lot to speculate about but you know
share your thoughts in the comment box
below as always you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell gets updated every time a review or
video is out we've got tons of cool
perks and prizes over on patreon come
join
our community we've also got t-shirts
and our Spreadshirt store I am Det John
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram thank
you for watching what much love